as the witch hunt against president
trump continues we have new details
tonight about hunter biden's attempt to
cash in
on his last name again hunter reportedly
used the trappings of his dad's vice
presidency to pursue lucrative business
deals with two mexican billionaires
i'm losing track of all the billionaires
by the way hunter biden's done business
with
does anyone have a list can we throw
that up sometime despite joe's promise
that he never spoke to his son about his
foreign deals by the way
photos from the daily mail show joe and
hunter
alongside hunters latin american
business partners there it is
i can see that on return there it is
right there there's photos
that's called evidence folks media
people out there outside of fox news
we have a name for that that's called
evidence take a look on the screen
you want to investigate that we have to
do all your homework for you
a year later hunter flew to mexico city
on air force two with his dad
where he apparently attended some
business meetings isn't that great
and don't forget hunter's taxes are i'm
sorry it's really just the story annoys
the hell i mean hunter's taxes are still
under investigation by the feds
you think there's any chance he'll be
held to the same standard as a trump
organization
it's hilarious here now with more
details fox news contributors miranda
devine
and new york post columnist and fox news
contributor jason chaffetz
guys thanks for joining us miranda i'll
go to you first
you know with hunter biden the most
frustrating thing about this entire
thing
is remember the whole laptop fiasco when
the fbi took
the laptop we had the fbi case number it
was reported what
seven eight months ago i don't know how
long ago we had the case number
all the media had to do was call the fbi
and say before the election say hey is
there a real case against this guy
because we got this whole
case number thing and they did none of
it
well i mean the fbi's had the laptop
since december 2019
and i don't think they would have told
anyone in the media if they had called
and asked about it they
keep that very close to their chest
let's just hope that they are
investigating it but you know the new
york post broke this story in october
we've run now two photographs uh one
this week of the
mexican billionaires having breakfast
with joe biden and hunter biden in the
vice president's
residence in 2015 and a couple of weeks
ago we ran
another photograph and another story
about how joe biden had showed up
at a dinner that hunter biden was
holding
at cafe milano in washington dc in
april of 2015 for business partners from
various countries such as ukraine
russia kazakhstan and mexico
and so our story this week today and
yesterday is about
those those mexican billionaires who
hunter
and his brother his uncle joe's brother
younger brother jim biden were very
interested
in parlaying their cash
into their own pockets so this is a
typical
joe biden who pretended during the
election campaign that he knew
absolutely nothing about hunter biden's
business
affairs overseas he said that repeatedly
he's now been shown over and over and
there's more evidence
on the laptop still to come that he was
intimately involved he used the perks of
his office
to help hunter and his brother jim biden
shake money uh using his influence from
countries and oligarchs and
and billionaires overseas
jason i mean listen how the sergeant
schultz media i don't know nothing i
don't see nothing
we have pictures of joe biden we have
photos of him with hunter's business
partners we have
emails literal not figurative literal
emails from hunter biden
from his laptop saying hey from miss
business parts thanks for letting us
meet your dad last night
i mean we have tony babalinsky the
business partner like oh yeah
joe biden knew the whole time and yet
the media is like yeah they take a
napkin like i don't see nothing man
what's going on this is just ridiculous
the lack of intellectual curiosity by
the media is disgusting when joe biden
says
that he's never talked to his son about
his business dealings
that is flat out a lie when joe biden
goes out and says that he didn't do
anything
about this that is a lie he called
hunter biden the smartest person on the
planet
now hunter biden has had problems with
drugs he's had problems with
guns he's had problems with russian
prostitutes he's taken
supposedly 3.5 million dollars from the
ex-mayor of
moscow he has deals in ukraine he's had
deals in china
he has deals in mexico he's flying on
air force two using the american
people's assets
air force two to go have these meetings
dad's lying about it
and now he says dan i'm going to get in
the art business and you're going to pay
me 500
000 for my piece of art that guy should
be in jail he should be investigated he
should be on the cover of time magazine
he's the one that should be doing the
perp walk
miranda i got about a minute left but
you know no one's knows this case better
than you especially the laptop i know
you've got some material coming out
about that
soon do you think there'll be any
accountability for this guy is this just
going to be one of those
moveon.org things where the democrats
are like ah that's yesterday's news
well we'll see i mean my book laptop
from hell will be coming out in a couple
of months
and everything will be laid out then and
we'll be
running uh stories in the new york post
in between times and so i think you know
it's really out of my hands whether or
not the
authorities are investigating we know
that there are some
tax investigations going on and i think
money laundering is
another allegation that's going on uh
federal investigations into hunter biden
so let's see what happens with those
as for the rest of the media uh i think
you know it's it's really on their own
conscience the
material will be out there for the
public to make their own judgment and
for history
to record yeah yeah they're a joke i
have no faith in them you guys can i
have zero faith and i'm done with them
all together so
but thanks for your time we appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else